[Applause]
[Music]
kelly clarkson honors dolly parton with
a touching performance
[Music]
[Music]
singing one of dolly's most iconic songs
the voice judge gave everyone chills
during the 2022 acm awards
[Music]
dolly who hosted the big night came out
on stage to give kelly her flowers for
the sweet
tribute that is so great
i was backstage trying not to cry my
false eyelashes off and
slinging snot every direction and tears
the prolific songwriter takes a moment
to shout out whitney houston who made
the song famous with her cover for the
bodyguard
i know that
whitney is smiling down on us tonight so
thank you very much
should be proud of that dolly gushed
over kelly to e.t leading up to the big
night i know you have a special
friendship with kelly so what does how
does that make you feel knowing she's
going to be doing that for you well it
makes me feel great that she's going to
be doing it because kelly is one of the
greatest singers in the world it's one
thing for people to do a tribute you
know it's going to be pretty good you
know but with her you know it's going to
be real good so i do love her to death i
love her personality i just love the way
she is and i have known her for a long
time but we don't get to hang out or
anything and i just found out just a few
days ago that she was actually going to
be doing a tribute to me so that that's
going to be special for me of course
and kelly chose the perfect track to
honor dolly's legacy it's hard to ever
know
exactly what makes a hit a hit i'm very
very proud i will always love you dolly
opened up to et about what the song's
enduring success means to her i was
proud of it when i wrote it i had a very
deep personal feeling towards the song
that was 20 some years ago and i wrote
it from a very emotional
place in myself and in my life at that
time i think it fits people that have
been partners maybe people that have
divorced people that have been lovers
children going off to school or children
saying things to their parents it's like
the universal language of i will always
love you and i hope life treats you kind
hope you have all you ever dreamed of
it's what we want to say to people and
i'm just so pleased with that it's been
phenomenal the success of it so whoever
knows what makes it i'm just so proud
[Music]